ursula von der leyen at elle quelque
chose à cacher c'est la question que
l'on se pose à la commission européenne
et pour cause sa présidente est englué
dans une nouvelle polémique elle refuse
en effet de rendre publics des sms
échangés avec albert bourla qui n'est
autre que le pdg de pfizer il faut dire
que tous les deux s'entendent plutôt
bien comme peut le laisser suggérer
cette photo prise à la cérémonie de
l'atlantic council en novembre dernier
est les échanges en question date
d'avril 2021 et portent sur des
négociations avec le patron du labo
pharmaceutique contrat pour l'achat d'un
milliard huit cent mille doses de
vaccins supplémentaires contre le kobe
de 19 et pour la coquette somme de 35
milliards d'euros la particularité de ce
contrat conclu formé et qu'il porte le
coût de la dose de 15 euros 50 à 19
euros 50 soit une augmentation d'un
quart du prix saisi par une journaliste
du new york times qui a conclu une
enquête sur ces négociations pour le
moins assez trouble la médiatrice
européenne et mini o'riley estime
qu'ursula von der leyen a tort de
refuser l'accès à ces sms et dénonce une
mauvaise administration
en ce qui concerne le droit d'accès du
public aux documents de l'union
européenne c'est le contenu du document
qui importe et non le support ou la
forme si les textos concernent des
politiques des décisions de l'ue eux ils
doivent être traités comme des documents
de lieux et la réponse de la commission
européenne a de quoi laisser pantois
elle explique que ces sms sont tout
simplement était supprimé ces messages
sont par nature des documents d'une
courte durée de vie qui ne contiennent
en principe pas d'informations
importantes relatives aux politiques
activités et décisions de la commission
des documents de courte durée de vie
voici donc comment la commission
européenne définit un sms plutôt curieux
quand on sait qu'un sms a en réalité une
durée de vie illimitée du moins jusqu'à
ce qu'on décide de le supprimer ou que
le téléphone tombe en panne cette
affaire est plus importante qu'un simple
échange de sms la commission européenne
est devenue moins transparents ou moins
responsable devant le parlement européen
et franchement plus déconnectés de la
démocratie européenne
alors la commission européenne
aurait-elle pris ses distances avec la
démocratie sur la toile certains ne se
sont pas privés de répandre elle a
négocié 4 milliards de doses au profit
de pfizer par sms privé l'union
européenne demande d'ailleurs si la van
der leyen présidente de l'europe de
l'est révélé elle refuse c'est le
scandale du siècle
ce n'est pas bien du tout madame ursula
von der leyen il faut démissionner la
présidente de la commission européenne
refuse de montrer les sms qu'elle a
échangés avec le pdg de pfizer la
démocratie européenne dans toute sa
splendeur rend le téléphone ursula il
faut dire aussi que cela van der leyen
n'en n'est pas à son coup d'essai en
matière de sms gates avant d'être
installé à la tête de la commission
européenne
elle était à berlin en tant que ministre
de la défense dans gala merkel
sous sa direction
son ministère a cumulé les problèmes de
gestion une centaine de millions d'euros
a été dilapidé sans contrôle pour payer
des consultants conseillers et autres
sous-traitants privés au même moment un
de ses fils david était associé chez
mckinsey cabinet international de
conseil en stratégie est déjà à l'époque
ursula von der leyen a semblé tenter de
faire obstruction à lenquête
parlementaire en effet deux de ses
téléphones portables professionnels
avaient été saisis pour les biens
blanquette rapidement les parlementaires
se sont rendus compte qu'ils avaient été
expurgées de tout message avant d'être
livré à la commission c'est à se
demander si ursula von der leyen n'a pas
développé une phobie des sms d'ailleurs
outre rhin son départ en 2019 vers
bruxelles avait été jugée aussi
inattendue que précipiter est considéré
par certains comme une fuite en avant il
n'y a plus guère de doute sur la raison
véritable qui a poussé ursula von der
leyen à fuir à bruxelles elle a laissé
les oiseaux parasites que sont les
consultants privés faire leur nid au
ministère de la défense et a donné les
clés de la défense nationale à travers
ces lobbyistes aux intérêts des grandes
compagnies du secteur de l'armement en
particulier dans ce premier dossier
ursula von der leyen s'est toujours
défendu en affirmant qu'elle n'était pas
au courant des décisions prises à son
niveau qu'elle n'avait pas connaissance
et donc qu'elle ne pouvait donc pas en
être tenu responsable
difficile à croire dans la bouche d'une
ex ministre de la défense au sommet de
la hiérarchie de ce ministère copinage
connivences conflits d'intérêts pour
beaucoup en tout cas il est clair
qu'ursula van der leyen nage en eaux
troubles